his caliphate may have vanished but the
propaganda arm of islamic state
is still functioning and this is its
most significant output for several
years
abu bakr al-baghdadi looks older and
more haggard than his 47 years
but still remarkably well for a man
reported to have been killed or
seriously injured in air strikes
his only previous video appearance was
five years ago delivering a sermon in
mosul
as his followers were on the march
capturing huge swathes of iraq and syria
at the height of his power only audio
recordings of his voice were broadcast
al-baghdadi remained invisible even
though the terror group produced a
steady stream of material
showing their fighters often committing
acts of barbarism
such as beheadings and burning their
enemies alive
since then is territory has shrunk to
nothing the final holdout and by goose
was taken last month
by u.s backed kurdish forces al-baghdadi
acknowledged the defeat in his video
condemning without apparent irony the
barbarism and brutality of the west
compared to what he described as the
courage and resilience of his followers
this washington-based analyst says
al-baghdadi has taken a risk
to appear publicly the background
was a white sheet the faces of people he
was with
were blurred he reportedly won't meet
with anybody with any electronics
whatsoever
this is a tape done by a man on the run
who realizes he's up against some very
impressive intelligence organizations
getting this out was a feat but he also
knows
that getting it out creates a risk
as further proof that the video was
recorded recently there were also
references to the easter sunday attacks
by islamists in sri lanka
and is's future seems to be in inspiring
attacks by supporters around the world
including africa the video will be
carefully scrutinized for clues
though the three faces of the men he was
talking to were blurred
and the background bare the best chance
of finding the elusive is leader
may be the 25 million dollar reward the
us has put up
to encourage someone close to the group
to betray his whereabouts
in woods sky news washington